大家好,我是小木头
本期视频
我们来聊聊最近蛮火热的一个话题
Loop Engineering
有人说这是 AI agent 时代的范式转移
那究竟是什么
我们在日常的工作学习中有用到它吗
它能够怎么帮助到咱们
本期视频呢
我们就来分享一下
先给大家看一条推
这是在 6 月初
OpenClaw 作者 Peter 发的两句话
没过几天就已经冲到了数百万的浏览
他说
你不该再用提示词来驱动智能体
为你编程了
应该去设计那些循环
来驱动智能体工作
差不多同一时间,Anthropic 那边管 Claude Code 的
Boris 说得更加直白
他说他已经不用提示词来驱动 Claude Code
他有一堆的 Loop
也就是循环在跑
是它们在驱动 Claude Code
自己来决定该干什么
而 Boris 他自己的工作呢
也就只是写 Loop
后来 Addy Osmani 写了一篇文章
把这波讨论收拢成了一个词
叫 Loop Engineering,循环工程
本期视频我们来看看它到底是什么吧
要理解 Loop Engineering
最好的入口
就是 Boris 讲他自己这一年是怎么变的
他描述了三个阶段
咱们可以对号入座一下
看看自己呢
目前在哪个阶段
第一阶段,逐行驾驶
或者逐行地驱动智能体工作
你手写代码
模型给你自动补全
大家还记得最早的时期
咱们用 AI 工具不停地 Tab Tab Tab
第二个阶段,并行手动
你或许会同时开 5 个 10 个 Claude Code 会话
每个都在干活
但每次对话都是你亲手发起的
你成了一
个调度员,在好几个窗口之间来回地切
很多重度用户现在呢
应该就处在这个阶段
而我个人或许大概率也在这个阶段
而第三阶段
你不再发起对话
你写了一个系统
让它自己去读你的仓库
读 issue、读 CI 的失败
自己决定该用什么样的提示词
驱动智能体工作
你从 Loop 里打字的那个人
变成了 Loop 的作者
总的来说
Loop Engineering 就是这
第三阶段
你不再亲手写每一条的提示词
你去设计那个替你写提示词的系统
那么一个典型的循环系统
是由什么搭建起来的呢
Addy Osmani 把它拆成了 5 块
外加一根脊柱
我们来逐一地过一下
第一块,心跳
它用来自动触发
也就是定时的任务
到点它自己跑
自己去发现有什么活要干
并不需要你来手动地驱动它
第二块,工作树
也就是 work tree
这也是在 AI 时代
慢慢开始兴起的一种使用 git 的方式
当然它并不是新事物
多个智能体同时工作时
各自待在自己隔离的分支目录里
互相不踩踏对方的文件
就像两个工程师各开各的分支
不会同时地修改同一行
第三块就是 skill
可能大家已经非常熟悉了
技能,把项目的规则、规矩写进一个 SKILL
.md,写一次
每个 agent 每次都会读
第四块
连接器
靠 MCP 接到你真实在用的工具上
比如 issue 系统、数据库、Slack
有了它,agent 才不只是吐一句话说
这是修复方案
你该帮我去开
issue,帮我去开合并请求
或者帮我发通知
取而代之的是通过 MCP
通过工具
agent 可以自己去完成这些工作
第五块,子智能体
把写代码和审代码这两块拆开
Osmani 有句话说得很到位
写代码的那个模型给自己的作业打分
有的时候太宽容了
所以我们需要让另一个 agent 来挑刺
最后就是那根脊柱
支撑起整个 Loop 循环系统的记忆
它或许就是一个简单的 Markdown 文件
或许是一块 Linear 的看板
把做过什么
试过什么
还差什么都记在对话之外
agent 会忘
但如果我们用这种持久化的系统
则可以帮助它记住这一切
那我们现在来看一个典型的流程
我们把这几块拼起来
Loop 的一次循环应该是这样的
比如早上定时触发任务
调度一个分诊的 skill
去读昨天晚上 CI 系统的失败
以及最近的提交
每一个能处理的问题
开一个独立的 work tree
一个子智能体来进行修复
而另一个子智能体呢
对照 skill 和测试来审查,连接器
把合并请求开出来
再把 ticket 更新掉
一旦有搞不定的问题
则丢进收件箱
等你来看
而状态文件呢
则实时地把这一切都记录下来
明天会接着跑
Osmani 说
这一圈下来
可以看得出来
你只设计了一次
中间的每一步
你一条提示词都没有打
完全由这个循环系统
自主地来进行工作
光听我说可能有点抽象
我们直接上手演示一番
先来个最小力
度的演示吧
把循环
也就是 Loop 这个词里最核心的概念
先提取出来
是什么呢
也就是目标 goal
目标通常约定
达到什么样的状态或目的
才结束
在 Claude Code 有这么一个命令叫 /goal
我们先打开一个 Claude Code 会话
输入 /goal
大家就能看到这个命令
这个命令的作用是
你给它一个可以判定真假的目标
它自己呢
一轮一轮地执行
每轮结束呢
都会有一个判断
目标达到了没有
如果没有呢
再来一轮
直到达到目标自动收工
我们现在呢
给它一个小小的目标吧
现在呢我给它这么一个目标
用 verysmallwoods research
获取过去的资讯和研究数据
提取其中 Google、OpenAI、Anthropic 的数据
直到凑够 5 条
这个 verysmallwoods research 是我自己搭建的
一个数据同步或获取的一个后端
通过这个技能呢
把数据获取回来
现在呢
它并不需要我每写一条就催它
或驱动它反复地做这个任务
你看
它并不需要我额外的提示词的驱动
它就能够自动地
根据我提出的这个目标
去完成工作
直到目标达成
现在只是完成了一个热身
目标达成了
那下一步
我们希望实现一个真正的循环
我想专门演示一个不是写代码的 Loop
因为很多人一听到 Loop Engineering
就以为这只是程序员的事情
实际上并不是的
它本质是
让一个长期进程替你做重复的脑力活
写代码呢
只是其中的一部分
我自己每天也会做一些重复的活
比如翻一圈 AI 圈新发生的事情
一些资讯
挑出其中值得写成文章的选题
这件事每天都干
特别适合做成 Loop
在这里要分清两个命令
/goal 是现在就跑
跑到条件为真
而 /loop 则不一样
它是按照时间表盲跑
到点
就把你给它的那段提示词再跑一遍
它并不判断完成没有
它只负责准时地执行
这正好就是 Osmani 说的那个心跳
我们来做这么一个演示
事例是这样的
我期望通过 /loop 做一个循环任务
这个任务中
用 verysmallwoods research
拉取过去 24 小时的研究源和新闻
挑出能够写成深度文的
追加进一个叫 inbox.md 的文件
再用一个叫 topic-scorer 的子智能体
给每一条呢做评级
再写回 inbox
最后呢
再用一个 --schedule 这个表达式
来约定是周一到周五
工作日每天早上 8 点做这个事情
为了演示
我们把这个调度的频度呢改得高一些
比如每分钟执行一次
我们可以改 --schedule
这个参数也可以通过自然语言描述
那我们这样改
先删掉 --schedule 参数
在上面提示词的最后
添加一句
每分钟执行一次
这样呢在调度的时候
它就会实现一个
每分钟执行一次的定时任务
我们来执行一下
它首先会尝试找到其中引用的 md 文件
inbox.md,以及可以用的技能和智能体
它也找到了 topic-scorer
这个子智能体的定义
我把它放在了 demo 目录中
我们再开一个终端
可以打开这个 md 文件
来看看这里面有些什么内容
分别针对每个话题呢
它都用感叹号、勾或者叉叉来做了评级
并且标记了是通过 Loop 自动追加的
到现在本轮的循环已经完成
并且给到了我一些比较详细的信息
调度任务是什么
它已经完成了注册
每分钟触发一次
这种在会话中的定时任务
是 7 天后自动过期
如果想要提前停用呢
用 CronDelete
那下方呢
就给到了咱们这一次数据处理后
追加的一些资讯或者信息
那在这里大家看到
这个定时任务又触发了
咱们来看一下更新后的文件
在 6 月 12 号做了如下的追加
接下来呢
它还应该对它进行打分评估
我在这里呢
就暂时退出了这个会话
就不再执行
刚才咱们就演示了这个定时任务
它是怎么工作的
这样呢
每天早上我就能打开选题收件箱
看到的不是一堆原始的链接
而是已经分好级、带着理由的候选
我只需要浏览这些资讯
按照它的评级打分来决定哪些优先看
哪些放在后面
并且帮助我来筛选
哪些呢可以进入后续的内容创作
或哪些更值得我进行进一步的阅读
这就是 Loop Engineering
落到每一个普通人的工作流上
大致的样子
讲到这里呢
或许还是得泼盆冷水
有篇文章写得还是蛮直接的
多数开发者其实还并不需要 agent Loop
我觉得他说得还是有一定的道理
他给了 4 条测试条件
4 条全中
做 Loop 才划算
第一呢,是这个活每周以上都会重复
一次性的活不值得做这套的搭建
第二呢,验证能够自动化
这点很重要
测试、类型检查
Linter 检查
这些能够自己把坏结果挡掉的
不用你肉眼审的
第三,你的 token 预算得扛得住
甚至呢扛得住浪费
Loop 会反复重复地读取上下文
重试、来回试探
这些都需要花 token 花钱
不管最后代码用没用上
第四点
agent 手里有资深工程师那套工具
有日志、有能够浮现问题的环境
还有能够把自己写的代码跑起来的
看看在哪里它崩掉了
基本上这四条都满足
Loop 循环看起来才值得搭
Osmani 的文章中
也给到了我们很重要的一些提醒
一个呢就是理解
Loop 越快地交付
你没有亲手写的代码
亲手看的代码
仓库里有的东西
和你脑子里真正搞懂的东西
差距就越大
另一个更加扎心的事实是
最危险的姿态是
舒舒服服地接受 Loop 吐出来的一切
这是非常危险的
在 AI 生成的内容中
越多我们不了解的内容
对于我们来讲风险就越大
还有个真实的失败样本
Geoff 有个出了名的循环技术
或许大家也知道,Ralph
也就是拉尔夫循环这么一个概念
它的特点就是锲而不舍
永不放弃
不停地执行
它也有个著名的失败模式叫 over-baking
发酵过头
你让它修个小小的 bug
它会跑很久很久
最后呢给你自作主张地
加上了一堆没人要的功能
甚至把本来能编译的代码都
改坏了。无人盯着的 Loop
也是无人盯着的在犯错
所以验证这个事情
永远还是在你自己手上
即使定义成了循环的任务
你也需要在适合的时间点
适合的环境上具备自我验证的能力
我们回头看 Loop Engineering
并不是又一个要追的新工具
它更像一个视角的切换
从我来写提示词驱动智能体
变成我来设计
那个用提示词驱动智能体的系统
必要的工具其实你手上都有了
比如像 Claude Code 所提供的 loop 命令、git
为我们提供的具有隔离能力的工作树
work tree
能够驱动智能体工作的技能,比如 skill
以及
帮助我们在一个独立上下文环境中
独立工作的子智能体
但别一上来就给所有这些事情呢
都套上一个 Loop
先挑一件你每周都在重复
而且结果能够自动验证的小事
把它写成一个 Loop
就像我刚才那个选题筛选的任务
这个任务的执行风险还是偏小的
然后记住 Osmani 说的那句话
当那个写 Loop 的人
别当那个只会按启动键的人
写完 Loop
我们还要有能力定时地
定期地在必要的环节上进行验证
好,今天的分享就到这里
相关链接我也会放在视频描述中
感谢大家收看
我们下期再见